Shashank.
Evan, good, how are you?
I'm good, I'm good. So, give me a second. Let me let me pull in Iqbal. Just give me a second. Oh, he's here. I can ask.
Sure.
How are you? How is things going on? How is summer?
Some of this, you know, it's pretty hot, pretty hot, pretty hot. It's kind of killing us right now, very hot, unbearable.
So, what?
Yeah, you can.
I understand. That's what I've been. I was been hearing about this from all my friends.
that summer is very intense across India.
Yeah.
Yeah, how's everything over there?
We have, we have two.
It was good luck in last, I mean, till yesterday it was.
Somewhere around 25, 20, 25, 26, but from last night it's been raining. The problem here is that they say some more, but we end up having rain on the weekends, which we can't do anything.
So.
Okay.
That's a problem. That's a serious problem, I would say.
Good, yeah.
Are you a bad?
What?
This can try to manage with it.
I'm good, I'm good. Sorry, I'm just trying to see why my, you know, that's why my cam is not working.
Hilary.
They can't see you.
Come on, after patching, after patch, no reboot. Don't tell me that. Omega will be behind.
Oh yeah, here we go.
Yeah.
I rebooted in morning, but you know I have to reconnect my camera anyway. How are you, Sushant?
I'm good. How about you, Iqbal?
I'm good, I'm good.
How are the things over there?
It's pretty much good. When can I just tell you that there is a summer here, so there's some time to go outside and have some fun. Otherwise, in winter, we are completely packed.
Keith.
Yep.
I was just planning, discussing with one of my team members, we are planning some campsite this weekend. He's excited. He was telling me that we are doing this, we are doing that. So I took student.
But Venkata is also saying that it's raining on weekends, so...
You know, when you have summer, enjoy the rain as well, otherwise.
No, no, I have, I got it, I got it, this new one, created new one, yeah, thanks so much, Javid.
Yeah.
At least you can stand outside and rain.
Otherwise, in winter, temperature is minus 10, minus 20, so you cannot even stand.
Don't say about winter, I'm going to kill you.
Correct.
No, no, I am not available.
Yeah.
No, no, not even thinking about it because Edmonton still have a winter breeze is coming in. Even though it's summer, they had a little snow shower last week.
The.
So, unpredictable climate.
Ohh, you're beautiful.
We are good in Ontario, in Brampton.
Yeah, at least, at least, knock on wood. All right, let's keep it short, Shashank. There are a few things we have observed. I know Iqbal connected in the past. The repeated mistakes are seems to be a concern for us. She's so good at customer handling.
Ohh.
Yeah.
Drew.
She's good at engaging like things, but...
Nice.
Only problem is that repeated mistakes. I think Iqbal can walk us through what exactly those are. And every time she's missing something, we are doing a hand-holding process, but still things are getting missed. And that is creating frustration to the client and either tier 2 or a...
You know, senior technician has to pick it and resolve it. Iqbal, over to you.
Thank you, thank you, Venkat. Yeah, Vishal, I guess Venkata said that, you know, repeated mistakes are there. She is good in customer handling, she is doing good. She's following the documentation, but I think there is something which either she has to write it somewhere that this has to be followed or something like which she's missing. For example, today morning, she's doing all the onboarding, sorry, the travel requests for us.
She's handling it, but there is a way, like, whenever they're creating a travel request, we have to exclude this person from one policy, and she's repeatedly missing this, we got escalation from Jennifer, one queen, one queen is a client, and Jennifer is by saying that in the last couple of months the travel requests are having issues.
Because I know whenever people are going somewhere, they used to create a request with us. We do the exemption and then the people are going out. So when people is, like person is out somewhere in Germany or somewhere else, if he's not able to log in, there is no way he can contact us. It creates frustration there. It creates frustration there. So they have to call.
Correct.
Their primary, although primary is in different time zone, for example, somebody is in India right now or Germany right now, the primary is in different time zone, so they have to call primary, other time primary has to create a ticket, so it creates frustration, and I can understand it'll create.
Totally agree.
And then, then, whenever I am doing the root cause, for example, in morning when I sit with, what is the issue? He mentioned that she didn't remove this user from the policy, and this is not first time she did. I think this is 5, 5th, or sixth time we have explained to her that this is apart from that.
the onboarding mistakes which has reduced now, like in couple of last couple of weeks it has been reduced, onboarding mistakes. Otherwise, onboarding issues are like this. We have our documentation which we have to follow, but somewhere she was missing something.
And the strange part is I have two, what do you say?
What is Abhi? Like, I just missed. They are students, like, co-ops, sorry, co-op. We have two co-ops who are not actually full-time workers, who are students only. They are sitting next to us and doing the same, following the same documentation, doing the same stuff, and there is no escalation.
Good, got your point.
Ohh.
So, this is something we just from the table. Apart from that, everything is OK. She is doing good. She is taking calls, she is doing tickets, even she is doing some other stuff as well, but you know, these small things create a potential effect on ISGs.
I just want to ask like for travel request, is there a document or is there a process in IT glue or somewhere?
So it is pretty much straightforward documentation. I think IT closure will be a documentation I can share with you, but there is an automation tool where she has to fill the detail and submit it and then review the intra portal, the conditional access policy, yeah, conditional access policies. So documentation I need to check, but it is.
Checklist.
It is something you know.
technical thing I would say, if you're creating something, you have to see that the user is not in other policies and you have to remove the SQL service.
Well, I mean, but see, I understand.
Yeah.
And documentation is there, documentation is there for everything.
No, did we did we give a walkthrough to her at least one or twice? We're given it.
not one or twice, five, six times even. No, Manish has explained this thing. You know what happened whenever you are creating a travel request policy, there are some cases where the person is already approved for some other countries. So you have to exclude that person from the policy. And that is a general understanding we have in IST. We have explained her.
Okay.
Hello.
Couple of times.
And this thing today, this time as well, she missed that thing.
No.
Yeah, totally agree. The thing is, I understand it's a general thing and some techs are following it. I guess if the documentation is there and the checklist she has it, then it would be better for her because she is repeatedly making this mistakes. And if she has a documentation in checklist, maybe she needs it for a month or so.
And after that, it becomes a habit. That's what I've seen with the techs who make regular mistakes, like they need a documentation in the beginning. So do not share it with me because that's an internal link. You can share it directly with her. Like this is the link. You read the documentation here. And secondly, for onboarding, I can see.
The things have improved, but still I let her know about the feedback of both the things.
Even one more feedback like I have given Komal as well, even Venkata has given to Komal, that wherever she has inquiry, she can ask us in our group, like Nexus chat group. She can post it there, somebody will pick it up, like Krishang, Gaurav, Abhi, multiple people are here who can discuss, even pick it up. If they are not picking up, I'll pick it up.
Karen can, even if we are not there, she can tag anybody. But what she's doing, she's panking individual persons. So, you know, if somebody is pinging me, I'm not on task, maybe I will reply after one hour or two hours. So, till that time, that request cannot be had. So, if she can just post it in that group.
Okay.
Correct.
Somebody will pick it up and answer it. This is something I have shared with her as well.
Yeah, I...
Yeah, this is the correct process and I'm not trying to defend her, but usually what happens if the tech, what the tech mindset is, if I post repeatedly, people will think that I do not know. But I'll clarify this to her. I'll clarify this to her. I know, I know, I understand.
Prince, we are, we are, we are a...
S.
The problem is we are asking her, we are asking her to do that.
Yes.
I am.
Yes, I, I...
I see, she's not asking technical questions. She's not asking anything which is technical. She's asking from documentation point of view. For example, who is primary, who is Kendry? I'm not supposed, like, I'm not thinking that she knows everything about Nexus clients. So if something is from documentation point of view, she should ask openly. Even technical stuff as well.
The.
Rick.
Okay.
Yeah, I mean.
We are very open in that.
Yes.
Well, sorry to interrupt. Yeah, sorry to interrupt. I mean, Shashank, like the team is like very well open mindset team and this team is the team is like the team what we are talking about. They all started as a level 0 like customer service agents and what we are today is something that we have built them.
That's one.
No.
I know.
Face by face to meet this technical standards and.
They're very open, I mean I'm not sure whether you have given the sites about how exactly the team chat room will be. It's very active chat room.
Like all the time people talk, keep talking, issues, they discuss, a lot of fun, a lot of things happens around. So what we're trying to say is that she's pretty good at all other aspects. There is no doubt about it. But the only concern is when she's exceptionally good and if we're still not able to, you know, convince the clients with the things what we expect.
That's a place where really things get escalated. Now the problem is we have a technical account manager for every IST. And this technical account manager is someone who interacts with the clients on a daily basis. Say example, the best example is travel request. Travel request has been given to the client saying that it will manage their.
Correct.
MDE manage detection and response needs if client is upset with this.
activity, they'll call off the MDE and they want to call off the MDE, it won't help a TAM to do any consulting to generate more business. So that's how they are correlated. In fact, very openly speaking, I told Iqbal to not to give onboardings, onboardings to Komal.
Because there are two big clients that we have, she missed it to do certain activities. The problem is that...
It's there in the checklist, but I think she overlooked it. Twice it happened, thrice it happened over a period. The client name is Maverick. The primary has reached out to me and said that Maverick and BIB together, if I'm not wrong. The clients reached out to us and said that we don't want Cobalt to be a part of that.
process. So we are not assigning that client to Komal. So now added to these two clients, we got another client, Averton. They said the same opinion that we don't want Komal because one of the user that she's connected, she was having some issues towards the latency, something she spoke in the initial phase that the guy have a similar.
what you call the similar mindset. So that is something we have already handled it. The problem here is if you do a repeat mistakes, we can cover it. One time, two time, three time, four time, yeah, I can do that for us because that relation that I have with the client. But they lose a trust on her, we can't assign a task to her. And when we are not fully utilizing the resource, what we're supposed to do it, then it'll be a problem.
Correct.
That is, that's how Iqbal is doing it because 99.9% Iqbal will mitigate it. He won't he won't escalate things to me because it's a daily learning and everyday progress. That's what we look at it. But if Iqbal was not able to handle the client, that's a place where client will reach out to me. So in these two cases, client reach out to me saying that.
Komal missed it. We spoke to Iqbal. Iqbal has trained her, but again you end up having a mistake. We don't want her. Venkata, is there anybody else who can give it? Now we lost Maverick like that, and we have assigned Urvash as a dedicated technician to support Maverick. And the same thing with onboarding on a BIM.
Remove.
There is a lady called Healey. She said she don't want Kobe, and we have given Urvash. So what is happening is that whatever activities that Kobe is supposed to do, we are losing the credibility, and we renotate it to somebody else who already been occupied with it. That's a concept. Rest all good. Customer handling is good. Following process is good with respect to tools and other things and documentation.
Yeah.
But you need to be a little smart in making the decisions. That's what the MSP is all about, right? There was some funny incident. Client went on vacation. Usually client would give that authority to us, but he believed in us. He said that any critical request come from this environment, I want.
Venkata's approval to be captured as a part of process from the audit perspective so that you guys can continue, which means if any client requirement is there, the technician has to reach out to me and say that, hey, Venkata, this client required this requirement, we want your approval. So what she did is I was completely occupied on the meetings on that day.
She sent an email from a connect device to me asking when can I can you approve it marking CEO of the company.
The CEO request, it's a CEO request. It came to her, and CFO is not there. CFO is given authority to me to approve it, and we are in the same team, same chat room. If you could have said that, hey, you know, Venkata, we needed its approval. And it is a common thing. We could have approved it. Even if I don't say approved, Iqbal can say that.
She she dropped the email, and with the amount of emails that I deal with in a day, I didn't look that because it is coming from the ticket. At least, if it could have been tagged me directly, I could have said, "Yes, go ahead." So, that day evening at 6:00 somewhere, I I looked at my Outlook Outlook boxes, I mean Outlook boxes, then I happened to see the CEO was saying that, "Hey!"
I was CEO of this company. I'm approving it. Please proceed. Don't wait for Venkata. Then I was so embarrassed because that CEO was saying like that it won't be good, right? So I replied to CEO at evening sometime at 6:00. It's odd hours saying that, hey, apologies, something confusion happened. We processed this request. Then I tagged her and I told her that.
If I'm approver, reach out to me if I'm busy with the meetings and other things, just informing one and go ahead. So those type of smart decisions, still she's not yet there. That's what I'm trying to say. She can make the decisions, but she's not yet there. It might be because she's so scared that she will do a mistake and she's been very cautious about it, but again.
We all did mistakes and I'm here to help people to avoid those mistakes from the clients. If they do any mistakes, it comes to me, I'll balance it. But when it comes to repeated mistakes, we lose the credibility of the client. That's what it is we're trying to say.
Totally agree. Losing the credibility is a big thing. And again, in other words, you are our partner, but again, you are a client for us. We work in partnership. So if Kumar does not do well, I lose my credibility with you.
Yeah.
So I understand. It's the same thing. I get it. I have, I mean, I'll need to talk to her and I'll work on some action plan and get these things fixed. I see these issues coming up and Iqbal just.
Anything.
to let you know like we are connected on team chat. So if you see repeated misses happening, do not wait for this call to happen. If you have some escalations coming in, let me know. And I'm sorry that I did not inform this earlier, but yes, you can connect with me on team chat. Our teams are federated. You can ping me directly.
No, normally we don't go into complain mode. Something, you know, me and me and Renkata used to take care of herself. Ultimately, she's a part of our team, so we used to take care of ourselves. But you know, in morning 7:00, we got an escalation. So then I thought, you know, let's discuss with you because you are sitting next to her.
It's not completed, it, I, I always see, yeah.
The.
Correct.
It's okay.
And you can pass that personal connect to her, because everybody sitting here is next to us, so we can pass that connect to them too. So, just let her know that we are as good as like the team we have. Komra is part of it. Don't think that she's an ITBD resource, she's a resource of Texas. If she have anything, any confusion, anything, she can just connect with us.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Sure, I understand your point and I guess she is into it because she was earlier working with a different client and not every client treats the team member, the employee as their team member, but after it does, I know, I know that because I have multiple engineers working with it.
Yeah.
Switch.
Well, I would say many of the engineers do have much better connect than me.
because they are an integral part of the team. I know, and with F2 we have a very long relation, more than 1 1/2 years, Venkat knows about it. So definitely, I guess she does not understand it fully, and maybe she is scared. These are all my assumptions, not.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
I'm not framing it, but maybe she assumes like this is client. If I reach out repeatedly, they will ask like she's asking, but I'll explain it to her like this is for own betterment. No worries. Like we'll see. Just one thing I would like from you both.
But the.
Do you feel that this is fixable or do you have less hope?
It is fixable. It is not about that. It is like, you know, how do I say? You're becoming more cautious and you commit more mistakes. That's what she's in that phase. I totally agree. That's the reason I clearly told Iqbal not to dump with every variety of tickets that we deal with it. Ideal expectation, like if you look at other ISTs and ITBD resources that are helping, they've been dealing with everything.
And we don't want Komal to go through that phase. We want Komal to be expertised in onboardings and offboardings. The reason behind it is that onboardings, offboardings are something required a more soft touch, soft skills and everything. And she have a really great soft skills. There is no doubt about it. But what is happening is when you become overcautious.
He's in the mindset that I will do a mistake if I miss this and she end up doing a mistake. And every technician has gone through that phase. That's because.
Kind of, she's kind of manifesting a mistake.
Yeah, yeah, that's what it is. And the best part with the Nexus 41 clients that we have, and these clients are like, like we did a handholding process from the time they onboarded into F12. They've been with F1 for three years, four years, five years, and I was there in their journey from the time they onboarded and from the time this ISTS has been formed.
So every client shares a pretty close relation with me, Iqbal, Karen. Like, I mean, usually if you compare with other ISTs and this IST, there is a lot of room where people directly reach us on the phone. Like, they call me, Iqbal, they call Karen and say that, hey, you know.
this happened. I know you guys are like looking into it, but I want something to be done. So we have that privilege. That's the reason we do multiple mistakes also. It won't get very aggravated with the clients, but doesn't mean that we shouldn't take it for granted because the sensible clients, whoever we are dealing with it, all the 41 clients are like.
Correct.
pretty, pretty soft-spoken clients. They know technicians by their name, by their culture, by their last name, you know, the hobbies and everything. When they call in, they say like, hey, Kumar, how are you? Like, you literally feel like you're talking to somebody sitting next to you. So that type of clients we have. We never had any demanding clients.
Even though technically they might be having some demands, myself, Iqbal, we generally deal with it outside the box, but when it comes to end user computing on our managed services, they're pretty soft. They are completely aligned with the process. Like they give good timeline for us to exclude offboarding, onboardings, they good visibility of the requirement.
And the best part is that Iqbal drives that. He do quite often a documentation validations to make sure that it is aligned with the client. Whenever client have a different requirement, he updates ITBD glue as is. So he maintains it. And across all the technicians, when they do any modification, they notify Iqbal, so Iqbal knows in the doubt about it.
I will completely relay on Iqbal when it comes to technical troubleshooting, even though technical wise I might have insights about it, but I don't jump into those major incidents until unless it's required. The reason is that majority of them we mitigate it, we manage it. Like Kushal, Urvash, or like one of the...
Senior technicians in Odario One, even if you ask me the tier threes like Art and everyone compared to it, they're almost same tenurity like Art, Kyle, and these two gentlemen are often working with Kyle and Art and everyone, so pretty composed team both with the customer handling and technical skills. That's the reason, like...
We were able to build more number in our technical team, and we were able to groom them up. So, only thing is that we need to make Komal understand that she can trust everyone within the team, and she can talk anything. In fact, she can share anything. There is no doubt about it. There is no judgment, because it's...
Okay.
Pre.
Because MSP is an evolving technology, whatever technologies I handled it or Iqbal handled it or you handled it, things might be evolved to a different state, but the basics are same. So we may not be able to say what is right or wrong, but we will be able to guide them where it is needed. And with respect to me, if anything she needed.
Hello.
Thank you.
Okay.
I can talk to cross departments because I have worked across different departments, so I have that good connect with them. If she's not getting the right information, I can guide it. But the problem is when you reach out individually, I don't know what's happened until this technician says to me. So example, if she's reaching out to co-ops, co-op is very simple. This is a three months intern program.
Their students, they come here, they learn and understand the corporate world, and we give them a certificate that will help them to gain a job once they're back in the market.
Our co-ops, Komal is reaching co-ops and co-ops are helping Komal. That was quite surprising because Komal is already coming with a background of technology and these co-ops are learning now. But co-ops become so fast because they are very smart in picking up things. There was a times where co-op is getting helped. I mean, co-op is...
helping Komal and co-ops comes to me and say like, or maybe technician comes and say that, hey, you know, we are helping Komal. Then I was surprised because if she needs something, Iqbal. The first point of contact is Iqbal and chat room. If Iqbal is occupied, then me. If we both are not able to do it, Karen is there. She's also good at ConnectWise.
So that's what we're trying to say. We want her to understand that we are one team, one family. Anything you have any concerns, feel free to share it with us. We'll be on top of it. That's only a thing. Or else, rest of the feedback is pretty good. And she's absolutely trainable. We personally have a high confidence and belief on her that she can be much more.
good than what she is now. So just, just, that's the reason I generally don't dial it. I'll leave it to Iqbal, but today I thought like today morning Jennifer's escalation is something that really concerned me because she's a little demanding one. So we need to deal with it right now, maybe second half of the day I'll deal with it.
There is.
feedback is fair, I'll share that feedback. I had a small presentation prepared as well, but if you want I can go over through it just for two or three minutes, not more than that. So I'll share the presentation.
Okay.
So the agenda is check in highlights, action tracker, KP analysis, CSAT analysis, V forward, upcoming events and recap. So overall, the performance that I see in terms of numbers, that's good. She's comfortable understanding the processes and her metrics are improving, but yes, feedback is taken.
Moving on to her KPIs, utilization has increased, ticket count is increasing, and CSATs are good like 100% over 11 surveys. And then we have this attendance where we have total leaves over there. So these are the things that we share, and then there is way forward.
I already have next steps for me. I'll work on them with Komal. I'll take her, I'll say, in a meeting room to discuss because I do not want to discuss in front of the text. That makes uncomfortable. But yes, I'll do a pretty good conversation with her.
Yeah.
And believe me, I'm not that kind of a manager who gets, if an escalation comes or if an issue comes to me, I'll first try and ask her, what's the challenge that she's facing? This is my first thing that I asked with any of the tech. So I'll work along with her and.
But.
You will definitely gonna, you are definitely gonna see an improvement in that.
Well, yeah, I think that that's what we're looking at. It has told good.
And if she needs anything, I'll let her know, like, if she is missing out on processes or onboarding and onboarding, or if she is missing out on this travel request, what is the major thing that she needs help? And she will directly say to Iqbal.
No, yeah, sure, like this, this is what I have already communicated to her, like whatever she wants, she can ping me, she can ping in group, like group is preferable, just post in group, tag me, tag Venkata, let us know, like we will complete it, especially from documentation point of view, I just let you know, I already asked Gaurav, we have created a IMAC.
Yeah.
Yes.
And he's validating all the document onboarding, onboarding documents proactively, just to make sure that any resource, especially sitting outside, like in ITBD, will not face any issue. So he's already validating, but still, if he face anything, I'll be there.
Sure, no worries. I'll definitely convey the message to her in a very polite manner so that the things improve rather than going south. Any other thing which you want to share, Venkat or Iqbal?
No, I think we are good. I mean, she's a great resource. She's a part of our team. All we're looking forward is to see her improvement in what she's delivering it. I think the rest should be fine. All she needs to do is that she should believe herself that she's the best and she's with the best team. I think rest all falls in her place.
Yeah.
We will see the progress, how she's doing it, and next connect, we'll see how she's improved in case if there is any areas that required attention, we'll keep you posted. And again, you are absolutely accessible. Iqbal will reach out to you and keep you posted about it.
Yes.
This is.
Well, I'll just ping you next week as well. I'll do either mid or end of the week to see if there are any other repeat mistakes coming up or how's her progress. Just a team chat, nothing more, not a full-fledged call. And if required, we can hop on a call as well.
Sushant.
Oh yeah, absolutely fine. I'm good with it. I'm good with it.
Sure, just.
OK, thanks, Venkat. Thanks, Iqbal. Thanks for sharing the feedback.
No problem, Sushant. Have a wonderful day. Thank you. Bye.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thanks. Have a good day. Bye.
Okay, right.